il existe 3 130 espèces de colibri cet
oiseau fascinant par son esthétique ses
habitudes et sa résistance il vit de 10
à 13 ans aussi appelée oiseau mouche il
peut battre des ailes 200 fois par
seconde
on a même découvert en 2018 une espèce
inconnue magnifique en équateur le
colibri à gorge bleue le mexique compte
58 espèces
on le trouve des colibris qu'en amérique
sur les routes à la mañana restait une
menace
on a fonction en 2014 maria des coraux
arizmendi a eu l'idée d'appliquer au
colibri une idée développée par michelle
obama la maison blanche cette année a
dit la première dame nous allons planter
quelque chose de différent un jardin
pour les pollinisateurs pour les
abeilles et les papillons dans le cadre
d'un programme adopté par les trois pays
mexique etats unis canada et non cadres
marien des le koro alès mendy qui voyait
bien que la présidence mexicaine
n'imiterait pas michelle obama a proposé
à l'unam la grande université mexicaine
où elle enseigne de créer des jardins
pour colibri avec des plantes à fleurs
qui les attire et qui les nourrissent
c'est un endroit particulièrement bon
pour les oiseaux parce que nous sommes
entourés d'industrie il y a des usines
alors tous les oiseaux de passage
viennent ici à la faculté d'estacades le
colibri est aussi un symbole profond du
mexique ancien l'animal km au charisme
c'est un animal très charismatique
les gens l'aiment beaucoup et il est
très présent dans toutes les cultures de
la maison amérique on l'associera we
still i pochelu le dieu de la guerre au
mexique on retire postés oui si les
postes-clés dans la langue nahuatl
signifie colibri de gauche
symboliquement guerrier ressuscité c'est
une divinité propre et unique aux
anciens mexique à les aztèques
elle n'a pas été adopté d'autres
mythologie mais pourquoi dieu de la
guerre ils sont très batailleur très
territoriaux ils ne sont jamais en
groupe il se bat continuellement pour
survivre mais les biologistes et les
archéologues aime davantage cet autre
association symbolique
los payos d'ios qualité associés qu'on
associe à l'amour et aux bonnes manières
parce que ce que font les colibris dont
l'écologie c'est prendre le nectar des
fleurs et ce faisant il remporte le
pollen qui sont les cellules
sexuellement des plantes et le
transportent vers les parties femelle
des plantes
il ya maintenant 140 jardin de colibri à
mexico dont un dans une ancienne
carrière d'asphalt celui ci est spéciale
car c'est ici que les colibris sont
bagués et relâché parce que 17 des 58
espèces mexicaine sont partagés avec les
états unis et canada
ce sont des oiseaux migrateurs live et à
l'amicale
donc l'idée est de placer une balle et
aux etats unis ils le font en très grand
nombre
si on place une bague sur un colibri à
vancouver et que quelqu'un le capture en
chemin nous aurons une idée de combien
temps durs exactement le voyage et du
trajet effectué il y à un colibri qui
vient du canada au mexique
ils pèsent trois grammes c'est le
colibri rouge migre sur 5000 km alors
qu'ils ne pèsent que trois grammes
ils ne peuvent pas accumulé assez grèce
pour voiliers une semaine ils m'auraient
ce sont de grands mangeurs dix minutes
sans se nourrir et ils peuvent mourir
c'est pour cela qu'il nous faut des
couloirs de fleurs même si quelques
espèces très locales sont menacés la
population globale des colibris et
robuste mais le réchauffement climatique
avance la floraison des plantes
annuelles qui les nourrissent
principalement ce qui pourrait affecter
leurs rythmes biologiques et leur
migration
jean michel leprince sera du canada à
mexico